- Education is the way
out for immigrants.
- Sure is.
- [Gary] My mom recognized
that I was a merchant,
an entrepreneur, a promoter.
- So did school fail you
or you failed school?
- School failed me.
School's failing entrepreneurs
every single day.
- Because?
- Because it's not built
for entrepreneurship.
It's built for workers.
You know, you're being
taught to play within the lines.
There's nothing being taught
that maps to the
entrepreneurial market.
As a matter of fact, my biggest
cynicism when I sit across
an entrepreneur today
is if they are too
successful at school.
I probably look at
Ivy League grads starting
startups right now
with more of a negative light
than I do somebody
who wasn't as good.
- Because?
- Because what I've learned
over the last
five to seven years,
and by the way, in the last
two, three years I've taken
a step back on this
because there's too many
entrepreneurial friends
who've gone to great schools
that have been successful.
So this is not a blanket statement.
But I will tell you that in a
world of private schools,
in a world of mommy and daddy
having a lot of connections
that when you go from
12, 15, 18 years of that ecosystem
and you go into a market
and you create an app
the market doesn't give
a crap who your dad is.
The market responds to your product
and a lot of these kids
have not been able to take
the punch in the mouth
that comes along
with entrepreneurship.
(light music)